っと
こんにちははじめしたそうです
皆様は白猫テニスというゲームやったことがありますでしょうか
僕もめちゃくちゃやってるんですけども白猫テニスの中でユニークなんラケットが
たくさんありますさあ皆さん白猫展示で行ったことある方なら多分
思い当たるフシがあると思うんですけどもあれが果たして本当に実際にテニスで使うと
落ち花白
か愛していこうと思いますアティ思います漆器たいですけど
4 p 4 k
今回[ __ ]ドゥン to do
日本人5年ぐらい
これくちょっとう寺の方の実際の提出を受けてみようと思いますまずサーブを受けてみ
ましょう
4位
はあああああああ
ん
[音楽]
me
はいというわけで準備は万端でございますまず最初に使うラケットはこちら
バットで打つ白猫と5で恋バットみたいなラケットがあるんで
これで本当に近いというか実際行ってみようと思います
[音楽]
r 2
乙葉やレーザーを開いてる感じだったんで次て返します w
tar
4の審判員が過ぎがあります
ちょっと素人の僕がとあたらなかったので別等の方に今回やっていただこうと思います
これで返せたら
フィールド天日本物ですかね
ああああああ
それじゃあこちらへ元品ですそもそも打つものでもないという
でもこういうラケットがあるのでこちらをひょっとしたら打ち返すことができるかも
しれません
ではやっていきましょう
次はこちら
フライパンです大ファンでは意外と彼等は何からケットっぽいんで改装と思えば返して
そうな気もしますやってみましょう
[音楽]
僕でも結構ライバー変えてたんでこれぞすらできる方に
ああ
いけそうですよね
マッハ
me
図1はこちらピコピコハンマーですそもそも小屋
圧縮するんでーなかなかこれで解説は難しいですよ
音も出ちゃうんでやってみます
ああああああああ
n ame
はいというわけで白猫テニスのラケットは使いやつバーでは使えない奴も味ました
ただやっぱか伝え所彼らにはもう勝つたいので今回特別に耐久のラケットを準備しまし
た後2つ分付いてるんで
ガットは2つあるんですよなんか反動を生かして外交強い意欲跳ね返るんでこれできゃ
いけないと述べフォローした
ちょ止めさせたと思いますミラーの猛追ぐジャケットみたいな感じですね
じゃあ行きますじゃあ
[拍手]
はぁ
me
ni
car
えっだけど白猫点以上皆様遊んでますでしょうか
操作勢がすごい簡単なので誰でも簡単に楽しめるのでゲームが苦手なあなたでも
楽しめると思いますしてダブルスもできるので友達と一緒にゲームを楽しむこともでき
ますぜひとも乗せてみてください
そしてなんといっても白猫といえばキャラクターだけどいいとございます
僕が一つのシャルロットも白猫テニスるっ
がいるので無事可愛いキャラクターを見つけで使ってみてください
今からこんなキャンペーンをやってまーす今から始める方チャンスですぜひやってみて
ください
そしてさっきボロ負けした別ランドテニスプレーヤーの方たちと僕のサブちゃんの方で
城にご提示の方で戦っております実戦で無理ならゲーム
高い
動画概要欄にサブチャンネルの動画もありますアンロードもできますのでぜひ皆さん
遊んでみてくださいじゃあな